welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
and today i'm
sharing or recording the very last early
on in recruitment series episode so this
has been a series where we've been
interviewing
recruiters who are early on in their
recruitment career to sort of find out
the challenges that they've been working
through what they've learned so far and
really just unpack advice for those that
are considering a career in recruitment
or are sort of in the trenches right now
their first year to uh two years of
recruitment so i'm really excited today
to be joined by sophie and holly who are
going to get to introduce themselves in
a second
but the great thing about this is
sophie's been working in recruitment for
just over three and a half years and
ollie has been working in recruitment
for over two years now as well so to
sort of tie this series up we've got two
recruiters that have progressed really
well and are a bit further down the
track so benefit even more from a bit
more
hindsight so i'm really excited to
unpack that journey so far
so before i start asking you both some
questions so if i'm gonna come to you
first if you could introduce yourself
and then we'll we'll get into things
yeah perfect well i mean thank you for
having us on um so yeah i've been in
recruitment now for like you said just
over three and a half years and i joined
recruitment at evolution where i am
currently at first ever recruitment kind
of role
and i focus on javascript freelancers
just in the nordic areas so across
sweden and
denmark and oslo as well
awesome and obviously for a bit of
context you did you so you went to
university but you didn't join out of
university
no so i went to university and did a
year traveling in australia and then
kind of just came back and found this
recruitment job
yeah nice love that now you got a degree
in biological chemistry
yeah so i thought i actually got a first
in there there's like a
biology in chemistry so definitely
different to recruiting javascript
freelancers in sweden
absolutely
cool and then ollie why don't you tell
us a bit about yourself
yeah so likewise pleasure to be here
thanks for inviting me um
i'm a business manager at evolution like
so but
i
um
work within the southwestern uk helping
open source mainly javascript and php um
engineers find their ideal role
i
didn't go to university i was very much
of
i'd like to kind of work from my living
if that makes sense um so straight from
college and i had a part-time job
at dublin's um and then went full time
after that and then from there just
worked my way up
yeah love that
so obviously
again just for a bit of context
obviously olly you work in the permanent
market right yeah and then obviously so
if you obviously do freelancers as you
said
so if obviously you recruit solely into
the nordics as you said
and then obviously
uk
but just southwest yeah
yeah predominantly southwest in the uk
awesome
right so we're we're always allowed to
start then so
so if i come to you first then as i was
just saying
i've got a first
in biology and chemistry
went to australia
came back
like how the hell did you end up in
russia and like let's just let's just
stop there
yeah well it was a bit of a mud journey
but
i think it was i did my degree and i
enjoyed uni don't get me wrong it was
fun obviously did really well i enjoyed
the social aspect of it like most people
do
but there wasn't anything i was kind of
super passionate about or i couldn't see
really where i would fit into like the
science world
and at the time one of my friends was
going to australia so i went with her
and i thought you know what i'll come
back i'll kind of
get rid of my responsibilities for a
year like let's just run away from them
and then i'll come back and decide and
see what happens
um so then i came back just before
christmas and really i just wanted a job
where i could earn some money get my
savings back up because i'd blown it all
in this one year in australia and
yeah and then i got approached by an
internal recruiter here at evolution
and and then it just went from there i
interviewed loved it kind of loved what
the company were about and to be honest
never thought i didn't even know what
recruitment was like i've never thought
about it before come across it in
australia
yeah a little bit but to be honest i was
more doing like
the backpacking side of things and like
just partying it wasn't really like
proper adults with careers that i was
really coming in contact with yeah
um
but yeah so then the interviewed here
started i think i started the middle of
january so it was quite a fast process
in terms of getting back to the uk
and then starting with evolution um
so yeah it was like definitely quite a
typical story of like
accidents like funding yeah yeah okay
and then what what about you ollie then
obviously you you took a bit of a
similar route to me really i had no idea
what i wanted to do so i didn't fancy
going to uni and getting into debt
and if i'm honest probably didn't have
the grades either
to be honest like i found quite
difficult so
i guess i i then found like sales and i
was like oh you know what i actually
didn't even know sales was a career
option really enjoyed that but like how
obviously you were to enterprise rent a
car like moved your way up in that
company before you then got into
recruitment so tell us a bit about how
you got into recruitment because it's a
slightly different
journey
yeah so like i said before i always
liked to i was like the thought of
of working
full-time as opposed to
coming back into education after college
so
i enjoyed sales i enjoyed working with
customers and that side of things i
really like flourished when i had the
opportunity to work my way up and
progress
um
i didn't necessarily choose
to go into recruitment um again
enterprise went my way up from the
trainee management side learn everything
about business aspects in that way
but when you get in in sales i found
that debenhams happened at enterprise
you get to a point where you're stuck
because you've got to wait for someone
to kind of out yeah that's um get
promoted or they leave the company or or
what have you um
i got approached by
one of the internal rec
here at evolution um i thought an
interview i could have gone in a couple
of directions like i could have stayed
in rental i could have stayed in sales
um like a business manager another
manager sort of thing um but i thought
i'd see how it goes um i got totally
grilled by andy brack the mda
he was really passionate within the
interview about like what makes a good
recruiter and the resilience is needed
um and i wanted to kind of prove to him
that i had what it took
um i always wanted that role where i can
kind of make what i want out of it um
yeah depending on how much i feel
yeah i think that that really is one of
the great things like i remember um
when i got my first sales job which was
um it was like in the call center so you
could get commission and stuff
before that i just did similar things to
you only where i think i worked at the
range for a bit b and q
did some domino's delivery like just
anything really and then when i got in a
sales job i was like ah like i can
actually be rewarded for the hard work
that i put in
over someone that could turn up do the
same job but like half-ass it do you
know what i mean
and yeah that was the thing i was like
why would i be in a
a job where yeah two people could be
sitting next to each other you get paid
the same if one person like puts more
work in the other
you can obviously provide that space so
i love that so i guess
yeah
and it wasn't just that as well it was
the fact that i had the motivation at
home
now three but back then two kids and
then this is like
i
i didn't get myself in debt because
universities couldn't have university to
go to but we got ourselves in bed maybe
me just off stupid mistakes so there was
like uh
it's like the advert with the headache
it's like that thing in the back that
you
yeah
i love that
so sophie back to you then so
obviously been in recruitment for a
little while now so i guess the question
i'd like to ask is obviously talking
about how you got into it but like
like how
like what skills or experience would you
say so if there's recruitment giving you
that you least expected
would you say yeah i think
it sounds really cheesy but i think it's
made me
really learn more about myself and like
who i am as a person
um
like now i'm i'm just so much more
willing to
kind of step outside my comfort zone do
things that you've not done before and
try new things
and
little things like we run a podcast
series ourselves and one of my aims next
year is to kind of go and actually host
a talk like a live event across the
nordics now sophie four years ago would
have absolutely died at the thought of
that like no way would she even consider
that um so yeah i think it's really
learning about yourself and learning how
much you can do even if it's something
you're not comfortable with
i love that and how
again just curious like how is that
showing up like is it showing up
anywhere in your personal life as well
yeah definitely i think it makes you
one more confident um and you just you
can achieve whatever you want to both in
work and outside of work i think it
shows that you can whenever you put your
mind to it all it is is a bit of hard
work and if you stay on track and you
keep within your aims you're going to
achieve it and i've seen that outside of
work um so yeah it's definitely helped
me on on both playing fields really
yeah and that's been really common which
is why i wanted yeah so i love that i
think that's such a great thing that
sometimes it may not be like sold in the
typical like recruiting interview you
know what i mean
you are going to be out of your comfort
zone and this is you could become an
even more confident person or could get
help you gain more confidence
so i love that and then what what about
you then ali what have you what do you
feel like you've experienced with skills
that you've gained maybe that you least
expected obviously you knew you wanted
to scroll into clear debts and
everything but
what else
yeah i mean at the same time i had a lot
of growing up today so everything just
happened all at once like obviously
met my fiance now um
having children at a very young age like
it was all scary um yeah
i'm 24 now but back then when i first
started working i
would have been 18 19 so obviously
everything had to happen straight away i
had to change my ways and recruitment
has given me a couple of things really
so
one that how business operates so you
know i'm learning each day like i'm
still learning and how different
business operate in terms of the ones
that i recruit for different sectors
interesting sectors that is as well
um
patience to begin with i had a little to
know patience and that's because i was
just so eager to impress and and earn
commission um which often let affect the
relationships i was trying to build
um and then also relationship building
so i enjoy speaking with people i enjoy
working with people um obviously depends
on depending on the client um but you
could be dealing with anyone from hr
tech team to owner in the permanent side
of things and i need to adapt my style
um to
to different people really
okay love that so
spoken about about the positives i guess
ollie back to you really on
let's just think about let's just sort
of
focus on like the first year for both of
you because i'm sure
if you've um gone through the process
of like speaking to people about joining
your team or whatever i don't know if
you have but a typical sentence you will
hear is like the first year recruitment
will be like one of the toughest that
you'd face or experience right so i
guess ollie back to you then like what
so you mentioned patience there but what
other
sort of challenges sort of really came
up in that first year that you had to
really work on in overcoming
so this might be live an excuse
exclusive to this podcast hashem
and
i was very scared to say no
uh okay to clients and candidates coming
from a customer service background
it had to be yes to everything and yeah
yeah exactly she had yeah yeah
absolutely um it led to me working
poorly qualified jobs with little
commitment
um
and then it actually led me to serve
notice due to doubt in my own self um
back in
my fourth month of evolution which
obviously was my first job in
recruitment
so
why did you do that just just let's just
like why you you came to a point where
he's like you know what maybe this isn't
for me or
i'm prepared to quit like what was there
like a lead domino at all i don't know
a number of factors really so
obviously
back then it was five days a week in the
office and there was obviously a cost
element to come into the office
obviously being in debt as well that was
the huge pressure on my mind that was
kind of stopping me from
not well it wasn't stopping me from
working hard because that's why i wanted
to get into the job but there's
obviously that down the mind that i
can't afford to live here and i always
got kids to look after and i would doubt
myself whether this job was was the
right move for me just because of
everything that just seemed to be
dropping off like i started off well i
think i placed my first candidate um
who's still going strong
um in my first month and then had a
couple of things come on then they all
dropped and it's like like if you add up
your potentials and they don't come in
it's like
have you done
so i learned from there never to do that
again
and it was just
it's self doubt and i think a lot of
people do it
since then i've gone on to clinch you
know five promotions within two years
broken a 20 year old 20 year today
revenue for the business and the verge
of surpassing you know a revenue target
that
i'm proud of uh for the year this year
and i think the business
as
a couple of people have done it in perm
so you know
it's all happened so quick but i think
it was that element of doubting myself
and thinking whether i'm right
in this role and i tell everyone that
we're getting into the you know we're
hiring for our team
you need to be honest you need to ask
questions you know you need to to work
hard
and make sure that
the qualification side of things is
strong so we do a lot of video calls now
not just because of the pandemic and
what the effect starts but you know so
certainly with knowledge as well video
calls were key um because you understand
that this is more but
yeah to say okay so
say it's saying that yeah i love that so
i didn't know that yeah so
okay so let's just if it's okay with
yourself let's just hold in on this a
bit early very quickly
because i think people can relate to
this because i think people will listen
to this and maybe even reach that moment
or have that self dialogue of like
maybe i should quit this or maybe this
isn't right for me right so you spoke
about what led to that
what what then so obviously now you can
benefit of going i'm so glad that i
didn't because this has happened
but what what changed in your mindset do
you think like what like how did you
obviously when you stayed and you
decided to stay i don't know what do you
think changed
absolutely seeing
like actually seeing the work that i was
doing
like having the
one two ones with my line manager james
um and actually seeing the weather i'm
doing isn't actually as bad as i think
it is because i wasn't achieving the
results there and then
yeah it was making me feel as though i
wasn't doing well
right if that makes sense yeah it makes
sense and then not just seeing the here
and now what was happening it's what is
available in the future and if i work
hard now and work harder than anyone
else i can actually achieve a lot
um
and what i tell new starters now is
you need to be prepared to put the
effort in like i think you mentioned it
before so like sometimes recruitment can
be kind of mis-sold
um in a way that you know it isn't a
nine-to-five job it isn't glamorous you
need to work hard and don't be fooled by
that um it's fast paced it's hard
working it requires to start on your own
feet
um you know
with the right black and support you can
make it what you want and i think that's
that's what i was doubting myself on
because i wasn't actually sure whether i
was putting the right amount of work in
because nothing was coming from it and i
came from the kind of work that i was
doing so the poor qualification
um
in that was the one thing that i changed
it was the video calls and from then on
it kind of stunned me changed yeah so
yeah okay
got it because i think i think and then
just to tie this up so for now i'll come
to you but i guess what's quite common i
think and i couldn't agree more is like
when you're
in the trenches
like you were it's hard it's hard to see
like what could be around the corner do
you know i mean like you might have
senior people like james go literally
keep doing what you're doing it'll pay
off but you're like yeah it's easy for
you to say that you build 30 grand this
month for whatever do you know what i
mean but it can be really hard to see
that the work you're putting in today it
can really benefit you and show up in
three four months time and i'm sure
that's probably even more so in your
world so if in contract but yeah like
i guess just to tie this up then advice
for someone that may be struggling to
see
out of the trees or get their head above
the water to see what the sort of hard
work they're putting out could benefit
them
what advice would you give them do you
think to help them better see what they
could be
achieving or whether it could be in
another three months time
speaks people
speak to people and
get them to map out what they think
you're doing right and what you could be
improving on i think
one thing that i can say about evolution
here and i'm pretty certain so for the
great is
the people here
are are genuinely genuine people and
they're training you know we've got to
invest in people platinum um you know
it's the world-class training here so
without that i don't think people
i'm not saying that it's probably a
hardship but i don't
succeed without that you know i mean
like
don't suffer in silence don't like talk
about it yeah
absolutely and you've got to speak to
people
yeah i love that
so so over to you then
so thinking about i know this might all
seem a bit of a blur now like let alone
the last 18 months two years but like
thinking about that first year obviously
your world is contract
freelance and did you do nordics from
day one
yeah
okay i've always done what i'm doing now
yeah yeah so what were some of the
biggest challenges that showed up for
you then that you had to really work
through and overcoming
yeah i'd say it's quite similar um but
more so kind of finding where to spend
your time because it's so easy to be so
busy in this job but not actually busy
with the right things
um so i think respecting your own time
is is so important and it kind of ties
in with what ollie said about qualifying
jobs qualifying candidates and for me
now i'll only work with clients and
candidates that can give me the
commitment that i can then give to them
because that's the only way it's going
to work out for the best um but i'd also
say kind of the first year especially
with it being contract is
building the book and and seeing the
money in return
when it's why it'll take you six to 12
months to to build your book up but
you've got to graft so much in that six
to 12 months for a little return until
you start getting your runners adding up
and you start building your book and
it's the constant thought of like you
said this is i'm going to do this for
the future me for the for the sophie in
six to 12 months time um because it
isn't you haven't run a start and then
you get the money the next month it's it
can be quite a long process to build up
the commission um
so you've got to have that in your mind
because it can be so easy to think what
am i doing like why am i doing this
yeah yeah absolutely
so just
because i think a lot of people benefit
right now and i think you've both
mentioned it and how sort of pivotal
it's been
just to frame this up and and so if i'll
come to you basically to talk a bit more
about this client commitment piece
speaking to a lot of recruiters at the
moment who like a sort of typical
sentence i might hear is like i've i've
got
live jobs coming out of my ears right
that that might be like typical sentence
i might hear at the moment
a lot of people are hiring and i think
right now
quite a few
people could be prone to like being busy
fools and like spending
time
in places that
may not um give them what they're hoping
for in terms of opportunity to place
people work with the right people with
that so i guess could we just i guess
just have a bit of a focus on like
when you say client commitment what like
just to have a bit of a deeper dive into
that because i think that would be
really helpful for people right now and
as you said both of you said it's quite
pivotal when early on that you actually
started to work or get more commitment
from clients and value your time so
i guess so if how of like for you now
when you say client commitment what are
like the non-negotiables for you when it
comes to
a client where or you partner with a
client like what do you need on their
side what things do you look for what
questions do you ask to make sure you're
then spending time and partnering with
the right clients
yeah um if it's a client that you want
to work with that maybe hasn't got a
live job we always aim for like monthly
calls like monthly video calls
everything done on video and just to
keep in the loop to make sure that they
respect your time and that they know
that when there is a live job coming
you've had so many chats with them over
the past however many months that you
know each other
um but i'd say with with the live jobs
which is definitely common there's so
many jobs at the minute um kind of
having a weekly call booked in to catch
up on these are the cvs or these are the
candidates i've found or these are my
challenges and getting interview slots
from the first call that they say they
need a job so making sure that you've
got the interviews booked in for you to
then go and fill um feedback calls as
well that's important so once you've had
the interviews making sure that managers
gonna dedicate 15 20 minutes to feedback
on them interviews with yourself
and i think all these things are really
important and they're so difficult to
get once you've qualified the job and
then you go away and you do all the the
candidate work and all the resourcing
it can be very easy to let the ball drop
and then you kind of stop wasting hours
with no commitment from the client side
of what you're going to do with all this
information now yes there's nothing
worse than like yeah taking that job
buzzing got a new job in start getting
to work like you said you don't have any
time in the diary with that client if
it's feedback if it's
interview slots whatever you didn't get
commitment on the other side
and you then call them i don't know
maybe 10 days later because it took you
that long to get some cv shortlist and
then they go sorry so but we've actually
moved the goal post slightly we're now
looking for this or whatever
you're like [ __ ] say
right yeah yeah so
okay so very quickly on this because i
think this is really practical and
useful for people
so
out of interest you know there's monthly
calls i've heard chris talk about this
before
like
just talk to me very high level like
why why why would i book in a monthly
call with you
but what like what we're going to talk
about
yeah um so one of the big things we do
is our own podcast series so we really
kind of air to the ground on what's
going on in the market setting up our
own podcast and talking about
interesting things so that's a good one
that we like to lead with is these are
the topics we've discussed recently have
a listen what are you interested in
let's get you on a podcast um but also
because we do know so many companies
across the nordics that we get on to the
podcasts and we can share information
like
remote onboarding or things like this
that have happened that maybe could be a
pain point for some of the clients we've
got so much industry knowledge from
other companies whether it be
competitors or completely different
companies from different industries so
it's more about sharing that information
and sharing that knowledge to kind of
add a value and and for them to say you
know what i've came off that call with
sophie and i've learned this or i've
done this or we had a really good chat
and i'm going to implement this so it's
like constantly adding value and adding
a service really i love that and then
the other point before earlier sort of
learn a bit more about your experience
is
so let's just you know all those things
so basically what we're trying to get is
a client to commit time to you or agree
on
time thoughts and these types of things
so
like obviously a red flag i'm assuming
would be if you suggest
hey what's typically work with other
clients is we book in interview slots
and this is how we work on feedback blah
blah blah and they go sorry so if i'm
like i'm really busy i'm i'm not going
to be able to do that
i guess what should what's your advice
to recruiters that may be getting that
to go well i guess you've got to then
get good at saying no right or you've
got to get good at going hey look this
is how i work otherwise i'm not going to
deliver your service like what what
advice would you give if people aren't
able like clients i'm willing to give
you that out of interest like what would
you encourage people to say or advice
yeah i think it depends on the situation
uh sure i think you've always got to
think of like win-win like what can how
can you come to a resolution that fits
both if it is the case of hiring
managers not having any time
try and think of a solution of okay what
about a phone call what about a call in
the morning when you're on your way to
work or what about on lunch like
anything you can think to kind of solve
their problem of not having enough time
as well
um but if it is a case where you are
trying you're suggesting things but
you're not getting the commitment it's
hard to say no it really is difficult
but sometimes it's better than wasting
your time
yeah yeah how would you say that
oh it's a good question that is a really
good question again i know there's like
nuance here nuances here right is it
something like hey sophie look i've come
up with suggestions the reason why i am
is because of this
but if we can't then
unfortunately i don't know like it's
hard isn't it because you want to leave
a good impression but you're saying yeah
yeah i think if you explain what i would
do i think is i would explain that
you're working with other clients that
you've got that commitment so it's more
beneficial for you to spend your time
there and of course don't say right see
you i'm never going to speak to you
again yeah yeah and we'll say if i've
got time i'll i'll spend some time on
the role but obviously it's not my
priority um and i think they can
understand that because they understand
the recruitment we're all here to do
business and it for it to be mutually
beneficial so i think just explaining
the situation um i'm not too sure
because i've always done nordic
recruitment yeah and they're quite open
to things like this like there isn't
really too many like huge huge blockers
like we do tend to find a way of making
it work even if they are really busy um
but yeah i know sometimes in the uk it
can be it can be even tougher because
yeah cool thanks for sharing that so
ollie over to you then so one of your as
you said one of your real pivotal
landings was saying no
getting away from that environment of
like customers always keen customers all
right to them being more consultative
being willing to say no getting more
commitment so talk to us a bit about
i guess what you may encourage some of
the team like people in your team now
with in terms of getting more client
commitment like same sort of questions
really what's been your journey with it
and how have you got better at saying no
as well
um
i still struggle to say now
um
that's me being honest um
with the
so when i change my ways of working it
was
it was basically because
i was just having a single phone call
and that's because i knew
from from previous like training um or
the ways of previous work and
recruitment that's how i felt it was
just a phone call doing a job
a job spec call and then that's it
you're going faster
i don't know like i know a lot of
recruiters like scott my team he's
really good at just doing that and
cracking on he'll find the best guys for
his clients
and that that works for him but for me
it's like a weird enigma that i can't
fill a role without seeing someone face
to face on a video call yeah really
strange so
i then just put it into perspective and
kind of stress the benefits to
prospective clients or current clients
that let's jump on a call let's talk
about it it allows me to understand you
more and your role and company more to
then sell to potential candidates um
yeah the people that we get into the
team are new hires and i work with them
on a strict day plan and that's
something that's worked
from the minute that i change my ways of
working a strict day plan being that
when you mentioned
when there's loads of rules going on and
where'd you turn to to avoid going in a
dark hole your day plan then allows you
to kind of structure your day in a way
that you get everything done and you
work your priority jobs but you're also
doing the most important thing that i
i think and so will also think it's
business development to allow your
pipeline to then you know help you in
two to three months time because sure i
see your improvement as your own
business because you basically are your
own desk you are what you make of it
um you're in control of what you want to
do so you would never stop your business
to fail you'd never set up your business
to three months down the line have
nothing going on so by doing a day plan
will allow you to plan that and for the
months ahead and that's how i've worked
ever since
okay love that
so now we went into a bit of a deep dive
there but i know that would be really
valuable for people because even people
who are two years three years in like
yourselves it's it's a real challenge
sticking point at the moment so
the next thing then i'm going to come to
you first on this i think specific to
both of you like
obviously let's just say we were to sort
of sit in a
typical interview of someone that was um
selling a recruitment job to someone
right like no doubt within there we'd be
talking about look sophie you can join
our company you can progress it's down
to you join as a trainee look at ollie
over here you've done it in two and a
half years like like you'll get that
right
but obviously both of you have achieved
that over different periods of time so i
guess what i just want to talk a bit
about now is
really i guess just unpacking maybe why
you think you've been able to progress
and
you've been able to achieve those sort
of milestones so far that a lot of
recruiters will join the evolution now
and and that's where they want to be
that's what they want to achieve as well
so i guess first you only really
obviously over um yeah the period that
you've been there nearly two and a half
years you've gone from trainee to
business manager
like why why do you think i don't know
maybe one to three things that come up
for you as to like why you think you've
been able to actually progress and
achieve that do you think
um so
i've shown commitment and hunger um
partially due to
um you know my whole motivations that
i've got back at home waiting for me
um
i'm prepared
whether this is the right or wrong
mentality but i'm prepared to make
sacrifices at home to ensure that you
know future life is going to be better
for them
um and by that i mean you know working
late whether that's in the office not so
much it's home and being prepared to
just be switched on whenever i need to
be
um
this isn't linked to
um like anyone else potentially well it
probably will because of the pandemic
but during the pandemic um one thing
that i found was that nick and gareth
and the owners of the business they were
very transparent
and they
walked through
the business and how they were operating
and if we did this how we would achieve
certain things and if we didn't do this
what would we not achieve um basically a
p l and what it was looking like and
that just spurred me on and i think
them being open and transparent made me
want to work harder for them yeah nice
i'm one thing that i remember in my
first interview with
with gareth um
the owner he said that we can give you
everything we can give you the tools we
can give the equipment everything like
that but the one thing that we can't
give you
is the motivation and the the work
effort you need to do that yourself and
that's stuck with me ever since
um
just working hard and being accountable
for your own actions is is something
that will make you succeed so you know
three things
commitment hunger and motivations
yeah just really really dug deep
okay i think there's a couple of things
i want to ask you more about that but
that i love that um
so for about you like what
why do you think you've been able to
progress and advice for other people
that want to progress or
yeah yeah i think definitely
like i said work hard you have to
sacrifice some of your personal life
you've got to stay late on a friday if a
job comes in even if you've got plans i
think definitely putting the hours in
and grafting is is key
um i'd also say
trust the people around you so my
manager chris my director matt
they've always been so supportive and
kind of
knew the best thing for me to do um so
trusting in them and trusting the
process that they've done and what the
team they've built
that's really really key and then i'd
also say playing to your strengths um so
i think
for me i'm like super super organized
like crazy
but i think that's like a real strength
within recruitment um
because it just allows you to kind of
forward think and plan and get you on
top of things um
so yeah whatever your strength is
definitely play to that and and focus on
that rather than
trying to constantly improve what you're
not too good on let's focus on what you
can do and what you are good at
yeah i love that
so on on this sofa i'm gonna come back
to you on this right so you've both said
and look this this is personal right and
i'm i'm really like my view of this is
completely personal to you and you make
your own decisions right
but like
i think it's definitely quite common for
particularly people who are early on in
their recruitment career to like
literally
just absolutely graft
where their socks off and like
might find themselves just grinding
themselves to a hall basically do you
know what i mean so i guess i don't know
if either of you have experienced this
may have may not have but
i guess any thoughts on like at the same
time let's be mindful of
i don't know what do you keep mindful of
to make sure that you don't burn the
wick at both ends you know what i mean
mindfully yes to you
yeah
any thoughts on that
yeah i've definitely experienced it and
you know what i i can't notice it in
myself like i'm getting better at it um
but it's for me it's down to my manager
chris to be like myself come on you're
kind of working too hard you're
overworking take a step back yeah um
because it's because you're so eager and
like you said you're so hungry for it
and in this job this is never a stop
like there's never a day where you're
like there's always everything i could
possibly do
yeah yeah there's no there's no end and
so it's something i definitely struggle
with
most weekends i'll work if i've not got
anything else better to do
so for me it's definitely
having someone around me who can be like
myself calm it down yeah but also making
sure you prioritize stuff outside of
work so a task i've done recently with
with my director is looking at your week
and looking at where you've spent time
whether it be in work or with your
family or with your friends when you go
back over the past few weeks you can see
that you've spoke to a family member
maybe twice and it's like well that's
the balance is off there isn't it so you
need to make sure that
going forward you're kind of
booking time in into your personal life
as well rather than just not having
anything to do so then you naturally
fall back to working
yeah yeah okay cool and i know this is
super personal right and i'm i'm
definitely
similar to you but i guess ollie what
about you then as you quite openly said
look i'm i've i've decided
i know if i'm i'm happy to sacrifice now
in
the future
family that you're building
is is in a great position but i don't
know any thoughts on that because i do
feel like it's important to talk about
this
yeah i think it's definitely a key point
i mean lots of people
simply bring themselves
to the role and would be a new role and
almost expect people around them to show
them exactly like what is needed each
hour of these day
those who are successful
take on as much advice as possible and
then go above and beyond without the
need for a kind of direction and
i think
like i've been told off by gareth before
like you know if you've been working
past 10 o'clock it's like only what
you're doing you need to spend time with
your family but for me like i've never
had that before i've never had that sort
of support and guidance from
that high up
yeah yeah commented down to my level i
mean um
but i think you know
at the same time yes i do give
time to my family and i probably do
if you kind of work it out i'll probably
give them all to work but
evolution is gen it might sound cheesy
and cliche but
evolution is genuinely and i mean
genuinely helped you know change the
life of myself and my family and i've
had a lot i've had to make a lot of
sacrifices at times you know as the role
can be very demanding but i know that
the long term the balance of family life
will definitely improve and work in my
favor
yeah yeah i think the advice there then
which i quite like to be fair is just be
honest with someone in your team and go
look as you know i'm quite prone to
work my absolute socks off whatever so
if ever you think you need to pull me up
or go look so if you have you thought
about having a bit of a break or
whatever
find those people in your business or
your team
yeah definitely so um no i love that so
a couple of things then before we finish
i guess
before i ask you sort of the sort of
final questions i'd like to ask i guess
so back to you
i guess if we were to try and put
together
your experiences and what you've learned
i guess if i'm listening to this right
now and i really want to have the best
possible chance of
finishing that first year in recruitment
on a high on a positive i'm excited to
go into my second year recruitment
what what one to three bits of advice
would you give me do you think
um
yeah i'd say
definitely keep working hard like think
of the future
um
you don't know unless you try things you
don't know whether it's going to work
whether it's not so just really biting
the bullet and going for it and stepping
outside your comfort zone
and i would say using the people around
you so
what i quite liked was that when i came
into this business there was a number of
top billers there was a number of
leaders that are so so approachable that
you can
have a chat with and everybody does it
slightly differently so i think kind of
learning from everyone and taking bits
of this person's success and how this
person does it and just using the people
around you i'd say is definitely a smart
way of doing it
okay love that
olly
same question to you
i think there's a there's two things so
make use of the tools so
evolution are a platinum investor in
people the training is literally
world-class make use of that
they put a lot of money into it make the
most out of it yeah um you know i
thought maybe not being a crowd might
have had me back but it never has
and the other thing is similar to so is
that you just need to be the hardest
working person in the business there's
no exceptions you need to work harder
than other person on desk 12 over there
or desk 2 over there
and
yeah definitely ask
take advice from the top builders and
sit down with them
you know i've had a couple of chats with
people when i first started of you know
how how you do certain things how do
they overcome things and it definitely
helps
yeah okay
so i've got two more things before i
both ask you the final question so you
both obviously mentioned a lot around
working hard work at these things so
ollie first to you then how um
how do you set goals for like like
you're going to be even more inclined to
work hard if you know exactly what
you're working hard for
talk to us a bit about i don't know do
you set goals how do you think about
your targets i feel like
the people that really get the most out
of their work ethic are really clear and
have clarity on like where they're going
or what they're aiming for
just out of interest
um
so being in recruitment has made me
realize that much quite good at chasing
down targets so i think
evolution are really good and i presume
every recruitment firm has it but these
like internal leader boards um and
target boards and that has made me
target where i want to go to the next
level and the promotion structures in
evolution pinpoint where i want to go
okay
and having an excel document for me just
to track my progress and then i sit down
with james um and even andy as well the
dmv um to kind of pinpoint where's next
and
the great thing about it is there's
literally no ending
yeah cool so i guess if you haven't got
that
you need you need to be talking to
someone in your team about having
clarity on like what i need to be doing
where i can where i need to be to get to
business manager what the job title is
so few is having complete clarity on
that which
meant
it's really easy for you to really work
hard because you know exactly yeah
there's there's complete clarity yeah i
love that
okay yeah
so what about you what talked to
obviously it's quite an organized person
you said so do you set goals
a bit about how you think about goals
and stuff
yeah definitely 100 agree with volley
there the the promotion and
literally what's what attracted me to
this job is i know every minute of every
day what i need to do to get to my next
goal to get to my next promotion
um but i think aside from the promotions
even just like
the basics of the job so video calls
with candidates video calls with clients
literally writing them down in an excel
sheet or however you want to do it and
knowing that this is my goal for the
week or this is my goal for the month
let me hit that let me exceed that so
that's something that i do like i have
daily targets weekly targets monthly
targets um and they're obviously on like
the very very basic level
i know hitting all of the basic targets
is going to reach to my end goal of
being successful and hitting my
promotions and
and and doing well within the job really
okay love that
so before i ask you the final question
sorry i know there's i've added a few
more but basically i have to ask you
this
so
what i want from both of you if you have
anything to share don't feel like you
have to but i want to find out from you
like
financial
a little far along
if you could um
let me just
is that going off
wait
like in your room
no i can't hear it
what i'd love to get from both of you
before actually the final question is
so first you only like
i'm personally right just a friend
that's up i'm actually baffled that we
don't get taught about finances in
school
and like
like i just i it baffles me right
so
i've been on my own journey on like
financial education
like just trying to learn exactly like
just what i could be doing right now
that could benefit my future self
financially obviously you've both spoken
about hard work hitting targets getting
promotions with that
obviously money comes with that right i
think sometimes not that it's completely
down to the employer but i'd love to
have more conversation recruitment
around
just more sharing of like or having
conversations around i wish i did this
when i was an amount of money or i don't
know just having a conversation around
it so i guess the question is
what what final i guess any financial
advice that you wish you had when you
was younger
or like when you're first starting out
of interest just just curious
um
don't don't spend on silly things
fair nice and simple yeah
just all right cool i'm happy with that
don't say yeah just don't you don't go
crazy
budgeting
yeah
like safe sorry wait sorry
i was gonna say when you're a young
person
like forced to rent a house at
18 19
rent prices
obviously this is my own game but having
kids so young
like there's obviously a lot of
outgoings and the budgeting thing was i
never had that support as a kid
yeah yeah nice
sounds boring
but
it's uh
it helps doesn't it like i've only
started doing that the last couple of
months actually budgeting and it just
helps
so if what about you any any financial
advice you wish you had a bit early on
maybe or maybe you had to learn the hard
way and we're not financial advisors
here we're just trying to have a bit of
a conversation around
money and what we do maybe differently
i don't know if i'm the best advocate
for this because i literally love
spending money
i love that i need your advice um but no
i think i've got better and but you know
what for me like being able to go out
and
buy silly stupid things and buy
expensive stuff and i'm like oh do you
know what i'm 26 i can do this not many
of my friends can do this it gives you
that feeling of life
yeah but i definitely need to reign it
in
no i appreciate it honestly cool so
final question so if i'll come to you
first i guess as you said at the
beginning of this like a lot of people
can find themselves
falling into recruitment all of that and
i really believe that like what both of
you have shared like recruitment
can sort of give you so much
professionally and personally so i guess
final question is just like why
why do you think or why do you believe
like like people should more people
should consider recruiting as an actual
career choice rather than that being an
accident
is the final question
yeah i think aside from kind of the
usuals that you hear like the potential
of earnings the trips away the
incentives
i think the people you meet along the
way are really um
like they're like-minded they're really
hard-working they're very outgoing so
the people that you will meet and that
you will work with
really make this job and you'll learn
from them and kind of make friends for
life really so for me it's definitely
the people that you will come into
contact with
love that
ollie what about you
i think i've answered today it's like
it's hard to answer properly without
reading off into like load of cliches um
yeah
but like i said before working at
evolution has genuinely helped you know
changed my life um
myself and my family
and
whilst i have to make a lot of
sacrifices i know that in the future in
the long term the balance of value is
going to be massively in my favor and
that's thank you you know to to
evolution
the training that's provided the support
um
you've got to choose your businesses
right but i think as an employer as far
as evolution goes i've never had
well i obviously had two full-time jobs
before us but i've never had directors
that sat on the same floor as you that
are literally walking distance to you
and will shake your hand and just talk
genuinely about footy i've never had
that before
um it's like society's genuinely great
people and you're surrounded by that to
learn from
um
so yeah yeah
i love that
so far it's been a pleasure excited to
uh
see how both your careers continue to
unfold but
thanks for uh joining me i really
appreciate it
there we go